PROFESSOR: I'm Sara Verilli.
I'm the development director
at the MIT Game Lab.
I came to the Game Lab
from the game industry,
where I've worked as a producer
and a game designer and a QA
person.
I've done an awful
lot of jobs and seats.
I've worked on Thief, Thief
1 and 2, Flight Ultimate.
I started at Looking Glass.
And that's actually where
most of my work was done.
I then worked at
Irrational for a while.
And that's when I
moved to the Game Lab.
I came on to be a specialist
in production, production
management, and QA testing.
And those remain the areas
that I teach in the course,
specifically.
We all do a little
bit of everything.
But I lead the lectures on
agile and organizing your team
and keeping it running.
And I also do a lot of the
testing lectures and focus
testing lectures.
What am I playing now?
Right now I am not playing,
but I'm hoping to play soon,
is the newest
release of Minecraft,
which has bunnies in it,
which both I and my daughters
are very excited about.
So I am hoping
that tonight I will
be able to actually go
home and arrange for a play
session of Minecraft with them.
I'm also playing a fair bit of
Sentinels of the Multiverse.
And most recently, we've been
tackling the Pathfinders card
game, which is
almost a way to play
an RPG in a short
amount of time,
except that takes almost as long
as a full session of playing
a sit-down RPG so far.
We'll see if we can get faster.
Right now, I'm not actually
working on any games.
I was working on a
climate change game.
I'm moving away from
that, and trying
to think about what is a
more interesting problem
to work on, in the area of
not just teaching game design,
but using game
design, using people
learning game design to learn
other subjects, as well.
So you can tie two
things together.
And I'm playing around
with how do you teach that?
How do you structure
a course that
would do something like that?
I'm actually really excited
to having a specific design
question that we're asking
the kids, the students,
to look more deeply into,
into making decisions
for the player, and making
meaningful decisions.
Because that's a part of games
that the simpler your game is,
the harder it is to
invite your player
to make meaningful decisions,
and to set up situations
where they are making those.
But that tends to
be the part of games
that I, at least, find the
most interesting-- the places
where I'm making
choices, and I can
see how my choices have
completely sunk my ship
or enabled me to win the game.
I like knowing that I, I
have control of my destiny.
And so getting the
students to get
to explore that aspect of
games better and more deeper,
I think, is really nice.
I'm currently also working on
creating a game with the Step
Lab Introduction to
Game Design on MIT EdX.
I think it's 11.126x, is
the number, I believe.
I've spend so much
time making the course,
I have not been looking into
all the administrivia tack
to do it.
But working on that, trying to
condense a game course into six
weeks, has been
really hard, and has
made me really stop
and think about what
is the actual important
things in game design?
I would like games
to go-- well, they've
already gone some of the
places I want them to go.
Games that are looking at
more social-- integrating more
social experiences.
Games that aren't just--
board games where you're not
just me playing
against everyone else,
but you're playing
as a team, and you're
playing cooperatively.
And video games are
also doing that.
They've been doing
that for years,
in the massive multiplayer
games, and things like that.
But seeing video games go more
for how do we work together?
How do we make this a
more social experience?
And what I really
love to see is games
getting to the point
where players get
to affect the games
back, especially
in the RPG space, where if
I'm a big enough player, and I
can now defeat everything
in the game trivially,
can I go in and change
the game to make it more
interesting for other players?
Can I take some of that?
And then, that actually
goes all the way back--
that was already being
done back in MUDs, right?
This not actually a new concept.
It's just that
production quality
has gotten so high that
you can't do that anymore.
Well, with all the
tools coming online,
can we bring that really
neat players giving back
into the game and creating
experiences for other players?
Maybe we can start bringing it
back into the high-end games,
too.